but first
i gotta pay a visit to a little friend
hello guys and welcome to another video
so we have an update regarding the next
episode of the book of boba fett so
let's get straight into it the
implication of den's words is that he
intends to visit grogu first give him
the gift he forge and then help boba
fett out i would imagine he's doing that
first and then returning to assist in
bourbon's big fight against the pikes
before the season comes to an end now i
have heard in the past that grogu and
even luke who he's with would appear in
the book of boba fett based off the
hints that we got in today's episode it
seems like that will be likely that
we'll be seeing that happen pretty soon
also surely din isn't the only muscle
boba's looking to bring in i suspect the
next episode will also show the man
himself reach out to various contacts
from the past people who may owe him
favors or at least willing to take his
money to fight with or for him this
could bring in some of the classic
bounty hunter characters many have been
hoping to see so i reckon we could
potentially see cad banging on bosque
but i reckon if we do see campaign he
won't be helping boba fett he'll be
fighting against boba fett anyway
regardless of how it goes down the dice
seems to have been cast for the story
we've been heading towards as he told
the crime families during his little
feast he intends to drive the pikes of
tatooine and consolidate his own claim
to power everything left for these next
two episodes is likely leading to that
showdown book would still include some
fun surprises so we know the end of
episode five the man who lauren says but
first i gotta pay a visit to a little
friend obviously this is referring to
grogu so if something doesn't happen in
the next episode that keeps the man
lauren on planet we are definitely going
to see him visit scrogu in the next
episode
now as we know luke skywalker was the
one who took rogue so we've seen goku
that means we're seeing luke skywalker
now we know in episode 5 the mandalorian
was struggling to use the darksaber he
hasn't exactly connected with the blade
yet and his skills in using the blade
could be honed a lot better so there's
been some speculation going around that
if we do see luke skywalker next episode
he may potentially help denjarin in
learning how to connect to the blade and
become better at using it and that would
make for pretty cool sin now we do know
in the mandalorian's new ship the nibu
star fighter now because there's no
astromech droid in this ship that spot
where it usually sits would be a perfect
spot for grogu to sit and so i reckon
this is a bit of foreshadowing for
grogyu to sit in this spot and also the
gift that is meant for grogu and you're
probably wondering what was the gift
that the armor of ford struggle well it
seems like the series wants to keep that
a secret for the time being so when the
armorer asks amanda what she should
forge for the foundlin no answer is
given instead the camera focuses on her
melting down to basca and forge in tiny
metal rings which could be for chainmail
if so this would be interesting since
chainmail is something that has rarely
been seen in the star wars universe the
armor is then shown tying up her
creation in a red and white cloth that
is small enough to fit amando's hand
while exactly what she forged is most
likely going to be revealed in the next
episode chain mail does make a lot of
sense considering the wound mando
suffered when fighting with the dark
saber perhaps he wants to make sure
grogu is protected from similar wounds
during his training now for the brief
amount of footage we saw of the gift
being crafted it does look like it could
actually be chainmail so my money is
also on chain mail armor i reckon
they're gonna just give grogu some armor
some extra protection and this will come
in handy if he does indeed end up being
back by the side of the mandalorian
honestly the possibilities for the next
episode are endless also the next
episode is curve written by dave filoni
and i believe correcting me when i'm
wrong he's actually directing this
episode as well so having luke skywalker
being back in this episode and
potentially cameos of other characters
like cad bane would make for a perfect
episode for dave filoni to write and
also direct also we know that the man
delorean has a gift for grogu so
potentially in the next episode he will
have a chance to give this gift to him
now this episode actually featured many
easter eggs but one of my favorite ones
was probably when the mandalorian
touched on tatooine to get himself a new
ship which ends up being an n1
starfighter which we saw these
previously in the phantom menace now
when the mandalorian took out the
starfighter on a jewelry ride little did
fans know that they were about to be
taken down a trip down memory lane as
mando started to fly away from was ezra
the rocky landscape he flew through
likely sides to look familiar that would
be because it was the same area where
the pod racing event took place and star
wars the phantom menace now the
attention to detail in this scene was
actually extremely impressive it looks
basically exactly the same as it did in
the phantom menace so that was a really
impressive job by the artists in the
book of boba fett another great easter
egg that i loved about this episode was
the bd droid now this style of droid was
first seen and star wars jedi fall in
order where he serves as your trusty
companion throughout the story so seeing
this droid finally make a live action
debut which is awesome to see and this
just makes me wonder will we actually
see kell kester's show up in the book of
boba fett or even in another upcoming
star wars live-action show such as the
mandalorian season 3. it would be pretty
cool to see and i think the character
himself would be around 40 years old at
this time so definitely a great time for
him to pop up there was also some cool
other easter eggs so the scene where
mendo is stopped by two x-wing pilots
you may have thought carson's new
partner lieutenant reed looked familiar
that's because he's played by max lloyd
jones who was a body double for luke
skywalker in the mandalorian season
finale so it's nice to actually see his
actual face this time around also
another easter egg was the word wizard
so upon mando completing his test flight
of the n1 naboo starfighter din says it
was wizard this is an obvious callback
to the phrase which was first introduced
in the phantom menace i guess the next
easter egg is a bit of a callback to the
star wars rebels series so the training
sequence with the man lauren used in
dark saber is very reminiscent of when
sabine vran first used it in star wars
rebels so in this scene sabine wren was
actually struggling to use the dark
saber a lot as well believe she found a
weapon heavy as well it wasn't until
kanan um instructed her how to use it
better to connects better to the blade
so yeah this is very reminiscent to when
the armor was helping danjarin with the
dark saber also while both the
mandalorian and the book of boba fett
are a departure from the films and even
the various animated series they're
still inherently star wars which has
always been about family and destiny
similar to vader and luke as well as han
solo and ben mando and grogu had yet
another father and son relationship
they're also on similar paths in terms
of their destinies with connections to
both the force the jedi and the past and
future of their kind grogu is being
trained by luke skywalker to become a
jedi and ensure that their ancient
religion lives on meanwhile denjarin is
being trained to use the dark saber by
the armor with hopes of rebuilding what
the mandalorians have lost reuniting the
two is sure to put them on a collusion
course in terms of their beliefs and may
present them with new choices and it's
likely that mando's gift of basket armor
for grogu will play a role in that it
will also be interesting to see how the
reunion was set stage for season three
of the man lauren and whether boba fett
and fanuc will have a role in that
continued story as well mando also still
referred to grogu as a foundling which
is a term for children adopted by
mandalorians according to their creed
families have the right to possess armor
and join the mandalorians when they come
of age due to mando's bond with grogu
and a seemingly renewed commitment to
the way is possible that he wants grogu
to have his mandalorian right to armor
and possibly choose ahsoka's warning
about detachment may also be wayne or
mando as well especially since he is now
feeling the full effects of being
separated by grogu after all when the
armor reminds him about the need of the
jedi to forego attachment mando counters
with that is the opposite of our creed
loyalty and solidarity are the way
anyway that's about it for this episode
to tell me what you guys thought of
episode five and what are your
predictions for episode six do you think
we'll see luke and groga again let me
know in the comment section below and if
you haven't already please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching